this is BC bud hi my name is Dave
Michael garg and welcome to BC buzz TV
today we find out what is the next big
question
as the scenes revealed we are at the
Vancouver Aquarium location of CFR's or
the canadian institute for advanced
researches next big question three
researchers from different areas of
study made a spirited case for why their
topic is the biggest and most pressing
number one dr. Curtis subtle how do
microbes change the world without
microbes there is no us there's a whole
range of microbes throughout they're all
very very small but the diversity is
unbelievable things which we call
eukaryotes which swim around there's
bacteria which most of us have heard of
if you didn't have those bacteria you'd
be dead too dr. John heli well what
makes people happy if you're happy and
you know it clap your hands if you're
happy and you know it clap your hands if
there's one single thing that you may
want to take home is that people are
happier when they're doing things
together we think for example that
income won't make us happier it turns
out there's twist in that number three
dr. Brian Kolb how do nature and nurture
can sort I would submit that perhaps
there's no more important question for
people to solve than the nature of the
human mind you are your brain you're
nothing more or less in your brain there
are a few microbes but they're not
really the issue here what's cool here
is that if you are really attentive to
your kids their kids are really
attentive to their kids well let's do
the experiment will take your kids away
and if your rat this is okay the
audience voted for who deserved the
crown of the next big question the votes
have been tallied and Vancouver has
the next big question is how do nature
and nurture consort the winner is Bryon
Tolle now what's the green angle you ask
we're lucky right now because in fact
it's the microbes in the ocean which are
responsible for reducing the build-up of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere and
so they consume a bit more than half of
the co2 that's produced on the planet
you said that they take in more co2 than
they're putting out is it possible for
that to become reverse and they'd
actually be contributing to global
warming some how is that even possible
absolutely and in fact I mean that's the
point overall the event was such a
success and left the president and CEO
of sea far singing the more we get
together together together the more we
get together the happier we'll be and it
turns out that's true for BC buzzmedia
till next time I'm Dave Michael guard